[Music]
it's a good afternoon
my name is Francis Perry I'm a software
engineer at Google and I'm also on the
project management committee for Apache
beam now today I'm going to give you an
introduction to Apache beam which is a
new open-source project focused on both
fax and streaming use cases now when
you're using beam you're really focusing
on your logic and your data without
letting details from the runtime
abstractions leak through into your code
and what that does is give you a very
clean separation that means that your
beam pipeline once you've written it
once can be run in multiple execution
environments I'll do thing that you know
and love whether it's Apache spark
Apache flink or Google Cloud dataflow
now to put beam in context in the
surrounding Big Data ecosystem take a
quick look at the evolution so what you
see here is that original MapReduce
paper in 2004 right in this paper
fundamentally changed the way we do
distributed data processing
now inside Google we took that
technology and we continue to innovate
publishing papers building systems but
really not sharing the code broadly in
2014 we create a Google Cloud dataflow
which is a part of Google cloud platform
and based on all this history internally
and this is basically both a programming
model and SDK for writing data parallel
processing pipelines and also a fully
managed service for executing them now
meanwhile the open source ecosystem took
that MapReduce paper and created Hadoop
right and an entire ecosystem flourished
around this beam is essentially bringing
these two streams of work back together
it's based on the dataflow programming
model but generalize and integrated with
the broader Big Data ecosystem so today
I'm going to go into more detail on two
key features of beams the first is the
programming model these are the
abstractions at the heart of beam to let
you express these data parallel
operations in a way that work over both
backs and streaming data in addition I'm
going to talk about the portability
infrastructure in the Apache bean
project now this is what lets you
execute the same beam pipeline across
multiple runtimes after that we're going
to get a little more concrete and I'll
show you how these concepts work in
practice will be a demo is the same beam
pipeline running across apache spark
apache flink and cloud dataflow and then
i'll talk a little bit about talent and
how they're using this flexibility that
beam provides in production
when final at the end some pointers for
getting started with using Apache beam
alright so we'll start with that
overview of the beam model now if you've
been to some of the other talks over the
last few days you may have heard this
example used a little bit I think having
a clear example for explaining difficult
concepts is really important so we love
this example you'll hear about mobile
gaming quite a bit when you're in the
data flow talk so I'll keep this version
brief if you want to learn about this in
more detail you can go to some of the
other talks and watch the videos so what
we're going to be doing here is
pretending that we've just launched a
mobile game right so we've got users all
around the globe on their mobile phones
doing some sort of tasks to earn points
for their teams
every time we score a points this is
sending with information back to our
server logs we're aggregating that data
we want to look through those server
logs and learn some patterns about our
users so here we have a graph of some
sample data that we're going to be
working with on the x-axis you have
event time this is basically the time a
user scored some points and on the
y-axis you have processing time this is
the time that score that event arrived
in our system for processing
now what you'd expect is that everything
appears along this diagonal line right
if distributed systems weren't so
gosh-darn distributed things would
arrive in our system immediately we'd be
able to process them and move on but in
reality of course things don't work that
way so let's take a look at this score
of three here this is pretty decent
right this score is only slightly
delayed it happened just before 1207
arrived in our system just after set
1207 for processing so this users
information was able to get into the
system pretty quickly however over here
the score of nine looks about seven
minutes delayed it happened just after
12:01 but doesn't arrive in our system
for processing until about 1208
so perhaps this user was playing our
game on the elevator in the subway
somewhere where they had a temporary
lack of network connectivity so it took
a little bit for their phone to
reconnect to the network and this
information about the points that they'd
scored to be able to make it back to our
system so in this graph of course isn't
even big enough to handle what would
happen if we had a real offline mode for
our game when we've got users on the
middle seat of some transatlantic flight
right playing our game for hours over
the ocean there we have to wait for that
plane to land that user to come out of
airplane mode and reconnect to a network
before we get events potentially hours
and hours delayed so these types of
infinite and out-of-order datasets can
be really tricky to reason about unless
you know the questions to ask the beam
model really revolves around four key
questions the first one is what results
are calculated this is your business
logic this is the algorithms that you're
performing over your data whether it's
some join histograms machine learning
models whatever you're actually doing
we're an event timer results calculated
just talks about how the timed event
actually occurred affects the results
are we aggregating things overall event
time are we trying to do it in two in
slices like hourly Windows daily windows
or even bursts of user activity sessions
when in processing time a results
materialized this talks about how the
time the elements actually make it into
the system affect results so how do we
know when we've seen all the data for a
given time period
and we can go ahead and emit a results
what do we do about data that comes in
late when those flights is those
transatlantic flights land right we get
more data away after we thought we were
done and the final question how to
refinements really talks about what we
do when we choose to emit multiple
results as we get higher and higher
fidelity do those different versions of
the result build on each other or are
they distinct so we're going to take
these questions we're going to build up
a pretty simple data processing pipeline
to use them to calculate hourly scores
for the team the teams playing our
mobile game so here we have a code
snippet from a pipeline that's
processing those scoring results
so we've already gone ahead and parsed
the data into some sort of structured
key value form where we've got the team
name and the number of points that were
just scored for that team
so in yellow you can see the what
question being answered right this is
what we're actually computing and here
we're taking those key value pairs and
we're summing the integers per key or
per team to get the total score for that
team
so let's take this code snippet and go
ahead and run it in a standard batch
algorithm now in this looping animation
you can see the gray line is
representing processing time as the
pipeline's executing it's and processing
elements encountering them they're
accumulating those elements into that
intermediate State that's trailing the
line and when processing completes and
the system emits the result in yellow
this is our final result you can see
here that were aggregating things
regardless of event time we're just for
takin all our data in one chunk and
processing it this is basically pretty
standard batch processing but as we dive
into the remaining questions we'll see
this start to change so we'll start by
playing with event time here we're
specifying a windowing function that
says we'd like that same algorithm
calculated independently for different
slices of event time so for example we
could do this every minute every hour
every day and in this case we're doing
it in two minute windows and so what
we're going to see when we go and run
this is now are calculating four
distinct results for our sample data
right based on the event time of when
the event actually occurred now at this
point in this diagram though we're still
waiting for the entire computation to
complete before we emit any results so
that works fine for a bounded data set
when you have all the data that you're
ever going to have and you know that
your processing will eventually complete
but it's not going to work if we're
trying to process an infinite amount of
data in that case what we want to do is
start reducing the latency of individual
results and we do that by asking for a
result to be triggered based on the
system's best estimate but when it's
pretty much seen all the data we call
this estimate of completion the
watermark so now the same graphs we've
been using before showing the watermark
in green
and it's basically estimating when the
system thinks it has all the data and
you can see that as soon as that
watermark passes the end of the window
we go ahead and give you the results for
that window but again
the watermark in a distributed system is
really often going to be just a
heuristic so here you can see that the
watermark is too fast
right we think we've seen all the data
for that first window we go ahead and
admit the results and then that late
score that happened in the elevator the
subway comes in and that user doesn't
get to contribute that really awesome
score of nine points to their team's
total so we don't want to be too slow
either right on the other hand if we
were too conservative with the watermark
and we were finding that we'd be
introducing unnecessary latency it's
really hard to tell when that last plane
is going to land in that last user who
is playing at one o'clock this morning
is going to turn off airplane mode and
send us their data so if we're trying to
be overly conservative we'll find we
introduce unnecessary latency so what we
can do about that is use a more
sophisticated trigger and so in this
case we're asking for both
speculative early firing since data is
still trickling in and also updates to
our result if late elements arrive so
once we do this and we ask for multiple
results for a given window now we have
to answer the question about how those
results relate to each other and here
we've chosen just to accumulate so
basically each time we emit a new result
for this window we'll get an even more
precise answer if you look here now
you'll see we get those multiple results
for each of the windows some windows
like that second one are introducing
those early speculative firings with the
incomplete results just as the data
arrived to give us an idea of what's
going on I just would be particularly
useful if you are windowing daily for
example and you wanted to check in
halfway through the day and see how
things are looking
there's one on time results for each
window when the watermark passes the end
of that window we think ok this should
be about it and in the net first window
we're also getting a late firing when we
encounter that late element of 9 to
update that we have a more refined
result
so what I want you to take away from
this section is that we had an algorithm
and we had a lot of flexibility with how
we ran an algorithm so here it was a
very very simple algorithm right it was
just integer summation but the same
thing holds for much more complex chunks
of user logic you take that user logic
and then you tweak just a couple of
other lines around it to answer those
other three questions and what that
gives you is the ability to cover the
spectrum between simple traditional
batch and some pretty complex streaming
use cases all in a single framework so
just like MapReduce and the abstractions
of math been reduced that they
implemented completely change the way
that we as a community think about doing
distributed parallel data processing we
hope that the beam model is going to
change the way that people think about
batch and screaming going forward into
the future all right so with that brief
introduction to the beam model behind us
let's talk about how this model can be
portable across multiple runtimes so the
heart of beam really is this model these
abstractions that we've introduced for
reasoning about the style of programming
now on top of this model the Apache beam
project aims to have multiple language
specific SDKs developers have very
strong opinions about their language of
choice that's not a battle I want to
fight we just want to be able to give
you the options right that meet your
needs next we have multiple runners for
executing that beam pipeline in the
environment that fits your needs all
right this might be on premise it might
be in the cloud might be open source
might be fully managed whatever your
current needs are and in fact those
needs are going to change over time as
your data evolves your company evolves
the technologies that you want to use
evolve so we want to give you the
freedom to change that and take that
same logic that you've invested so much
time in building and be able to run it
in those different environments now this
diagram gets a little more complicated
right because what each of those runners
is doing when it executes your pipeline
is calling back into those language
specific SDKs to execute your per
element processing your Maps on
basically so what we've done is a
project is built out a second layer of
internal API that really cleanly
separate the runners and how they're
organizing and distributing the
processing from the line the per element
processing that's written in those
custom languages and by doing that we
make it very easy for the community to
evolve these components in parallel you
can add a new runner without knowing
details about each of those SDKs and you
can add a new SDK
without knowing the guts of how those
runners work and getting this layer
correct is incredibly important because
this is the data intensive path this is
the path that's happening essentially
per element or per bundle at a very
fine-grain and so you need to be able to
get this in the right place and be able
to get the performance that people need
out of these big data systems all right
so this is a being vision this is what
Apache beam is aiming to be we're not
there yet
right this is where we are so currently
we have the Java SDK it's quite mature
and it runs across a number of different
runners so SPARC Flinx data flow and
apex or on the main master branch and we
have Apache gear pump under development
now the Python SDK has also just merged
into the master branch but we don't yet
have that bottom level of the the
function portability layer in place to
allow the Python SDK to run across all
the other runners so currently we only
have support for the Python SDK to run
at scale in batch mode on cloud dataflow
so but we're actively working towards
building that out so let's go into a
little more detail about some of these
runners so these three were the original
runners that were part of the Apache
bean project and they're also the three
I'm going to be demoing in just a minute
so you know many of you are probably
familiar with Apache spark so a very
popular choice right now in the big data
world and it really excels in memory and
interactive style computations Apache
flink is a bit more of a newcomer to the
broader big data ecosystem but it has
some really clean and excellent
semantics for doing stream processing
and finally cloud dataflow right this is
Google cloud platform fully managed
service for data processing and this
evolved along with sort of the
technology at the heart of beam in those
years of internal work
Google so each of these runners does
parallel data processing but they need
to do them in a slightly different way
all right so the question is how are we
going to build an abstraction layer that
takes these very different things
and generalizes them into one thing so
one option would be to just take the
intersection of what all the different
runners can do but that's not going to
be nearly interesting enough right
that's just going to be a small slice of
what data processing is capable of on
the other hand if we try to take the
Union and include all the functionality
that all the runners possibly have we'd
end up with a real big kitchen sink of
chaos right it'd be really complicated
hard to understand it wouldn't be this
clean crisp programming model that makes
things complex tasks easy and that's
really what we're after so instead what
we're trying to do with bean is be at
the forefront of where data processing
is going both pushing functionality into
and pulling patterns out of those
underlying runtime engines so keyed
state is a great example of a feature
that existed in some of these engines
for a while it was very useful for
stream processing these cases but it
didn't exist in beam originally so we've
worked with the beam community to
understand how cube state is implemented
across these different runners and
really pull up an abstraction and a
notion of this feature that fits cleanly
in the beam model and integrates nicely
with our other semantics on the other
hand we also hope that beam will
influence the roadmaps of each of these
individual engines so for example the
semantics of flink uses right now for
their data streams was heavily
influenced by a lot of the early work we
did on the beam model
this also means though at times that
there may be a divergence between the
general power of the beam model and what
different runners are currently capable
of implementing because we're going to
pull something into the model when we're
convinced it's the right way for data
processing to move forward not all of
the runners may be able to build on that
yet so what we're going to do in the
beam project is track that very clearly
on the website and the capability matrix
right and I don't I don't think you
should take this as an example that some
of these runners just aren't worth
anything
I think what it means is that there are
significant use cases that don't mean
some of these features right batch
processing is something we've all been
doing for years all of these runners are
great at that right some of the more
semantical semantic differences between
event time and processing time are still
really filtering out into the broader
big data ecosystem as a whole and you're
seeing these engines make significant
improvements towards those things over
time so I mean our goal as a project is
really to be establishing the the
high-water mark of what data processing
should be and helping everyone else
implement that well all right so with
those concepts behind us the brief
overview of the model and the discussion
of portability I'd like to get hands-on
and dive into a demo so what we're going
to do now is swap to my laptop and
actually see of something pipeline in
progress so what we have here is a very
simple batch pipeline that's taking a
bunch of the server logs for each line
represents the user scoring points for
their team and we're trying to calculate
the hourly team scores so per our window
to our would it each team score across
all the users on that team so you can
see here we're starting we're going to
parse some arguments then tell the
system that we're going to start
creating a pipeline right here and then
once we do that we're building the
pipeline structure by adding
transformations to it so we'll start by
reading new lines eliminated text from
from an input file and then we'll take
each of those lines a new line delimited
text and go off and parse it so this is
basically the map functions right that
you know and love I happen to be using
Java 7 here if I was using Java 8
there's some lambdas and things we can
be doing as well but if you dive into
the body of this user processing
function you'll see that it's an
element-wise processing it's taking a
string in this case that would be that
line of long text and turning it into a
more structured format a game action
info object so that we're able to more
easily interact with it so we're going
to for each element we're going to grab
the elements we're going to split it to
commas try to extract those pieces and
you'll see that at the end there we're
going to build that more structured
format now as we're going we might
encounter a parse error in fact will
almost certainly
parsers since I sneakily injected some
into the input data and so what we want
to do there is go ahead and catch that
exception and we're going to increment a
counter right and log the lanza method
and keep going because we're going to
want to build a pipeline that's
resilient to these kinds of things
because you can never trust your input
data to be as clean as you'd like so
we've spent that part structure let's go
back down to the main method so now you
can see we're going to set the time
stamps and what this will do is take
that time stamp that we parsed out of
the log line and set it as the metadata
time stamp on that element this allows
the system to interact with the time
stamp of that element and it will use
that information to do things like
adjust the way when doing and triggering
behave next we'll go ahead and ask to
calculate one-hour fixed windows of our
answer and then we'll ask to run our
calculate team scores transform now this
is a composite transform that we wrote
that basically means it's a sub graph of
more information and this sub graph is
going to take a P collection of those
game action info and return us an MVP
collection because it's actually
collection of voids because it's
actually going to go ahead and write
them straight out to files and the body
here is that we're going to extract the
team in the score and then we're going
to sum those integers per team so that
we have the score for that given team
and then we're going to go ahead and
write it out to a file with one file per
hour okay so that's basically the
structure of this pipeline so let's pop
over for a minute and take a look at the
input data so I'm going to run over a
handful of CSV files each of them you
know 12 12 to 30 gigs so a decent amount
of data and not a huge amount and then
when we go and execute that pipeline
Here I am running this pipeline on cloud
dataflow so what you can see here is
this is the structure of that code I
built so there's our read our parse our
set time stamps here's our composite
operation down here the sum team scores
and you can see it gives us a way to pop
in and see that internal structure that
we built this way of sort of expressing
that composite structure of your
pipeline to your monitoring UI is hugely
useful if you've ever seen
are letting you monitor these pipelines
the dag that you're looking at is like
this big and it's completely impossible
to make any sense of it
so this basically lets you as a
programmer you know you're used to
thinking modular lis this lets you add
that structure into your pipeline and
the way that the system is able to speak
it back to you so you can see that this
job is running with the apache vm sdk
for java zero six this is actually the
release candidate of next week's release
ran for nine minutes you'll see that
some of these stages reported that they
ran for longer than that that's because
this is summed up over all the workers
that were actually executing so down
here you can see dataflow chose to auto
scale to 15 workers to run the size of
data if we scroll down you can also see
those parsers that we were counting or
trapped here so we can see as the
pipeline is executing if this is already
completed if it we're running in CDs
picking up as we were encountering those
parsers so that's this running on data
flow we can go we can check our our
output directory for the data flow
directory you can look and you can see
basically we're getting one input file
per hour here we can pop in and see
there's the team names
there's the scores for those teams right
I made up the team names so there you go
so that's what the pipeline looks like
running on data flow but I also want to
take that exact same pipeline now I'm
going to run it on two other runners so
over here I have SPARC runner so I've
got a smart cluster up and I've run that
that exact same pipeline so you can see
that as we dive into here basically this
is a sparks definition of that high
level dag so you can see what you're
seeing here is basically that original
math and parsing phase then there's that
first combine that comes from the
summing across the keys and this is that
second group by key that we're using to
organize the output files so if we go
down of those three phases really the
one with all the guts in it is this
first one right because any distributed
processing engine worth its salt does as
much pre combining as it can before it
starts shuffling so when you go down and
look at the comparative size of these
these three stages right the all the
goodness is in here so now you're
starting to see that the dag for this
stage that looks more like the code that
we were writing
so there's our our read we've got our
parse game here setting our time stamps
down to that pre combine if you dig in
here again you'll see the shuffle data
that's being written out is relatively
small if we look into the event timeline
a bit you can see each of the parallel
workers setting up their tasks going
ahead and processing their data it takes
a little bit variable amount of time and
so on so one thing that's a little bit
difficult to see in the SPARC UI is the
amount of input data so if you look it
looks like none of these stages are
actually reading any data because this
is only tracking data read to and from
and you can spark storage in this case
I'm using GCS to store my data it
doesn't matter which of these runners
you're running on we have a unified IO
API that means that you can use that
same IO connector across all of the beam
runners the beam runners just support
the just implement support for the
generic be Myo and then they're able to
get all of this functionality if we swap
over to the flink runner so here's the
same job again running on apache flink
if I pop in look at that again there's a
dag cause she's starting to feel
familiar all right so you can see the
dag it's a little bit different here we
have the read in flink
there's our parse events our combines
coming up over there here you can really
see the the data sizes show up a little
better as the transition between stages
so there's a hundred and nine gigs spent
spent from that first agents link to the
second one you can see the number of
records that are involved here a little
more heavily and if you go up and look
in the accumulators again you can see in
that part's event you know there's the
number of errors that we're encountering
if you're really able to see that the
same pipeline is running at scale across
all of these different engines so at
this point what I've shown you is just
that batch pipeline running I want to
also show you a streaming pipeline so
here I have a second main method it's
built up this time is a streaming
pipeline and it's going to read from
Google cloud pub/sub right so it's
basically reading an infinite amount of
data so it will just continue coming and
coming we're going to use that exact
same parsing logic that we had before
this time we don't have to set
time stamps by hand the system is able
to gather them directly out of pub/sub
we're going to use a slightly more
advanced windowing algorithm because we
want to take this and transform it into
streaming mode we don't just want to
wait right for everything to complete to
get those results we want that low
latency so here we're going to ask to
trigger the windows when the watermark
is past the end of the window and also
ask for some early speculative firings
and that late firing every time we see a
late element but then after that after
that initial slightly different initial
setup we're going to run that same
calculate team scores transform that
we've written before right and again
this is a decently simple one so that I
could explain it to you but it doesn't
matter the kinds of complex logic you
have you can reuse that same logic
across these two modes across both
bounded fixed sized data sets and
unbounded data sets so if we take this
we can pop over and we're going to see
it running here in data flow so here's
that that same pipeline with that same
composite transform running down there
right and you can see now it's a
streaming job been running since
yesterday it's only chosen to use three
workers the auto scaling just stopped at
three here because I'm I'm injecting the
data with a single threaded machine so
there's not a huge load of data it's
processing you know nearly 2,000
elements per second you can see over
since yesterday it's processed 43 gigs
of data and one of the things that's
most important in the streaming pipeline
is to keep up with the amount of data
that's coming in as you can see here
we're tracking the data water market
1507 it's 1508 so that's pretty decent
we're keeping up with with real-time as
we're processing this alright so that's
the demo that I've got today so let's go
ahead and pop back to the slides so now
what I'd like to show you I talked about
a little bit is a you custom the
customer actually able to use this in
production so talent is a Google cloud
partner and they build open-source big
data integration solutions so talent
data preparation the self-service
solution that enables their customers to
access cleanse and analyze their data
and it's available as both an
open-source release and also an
Enterprise version they also have a new
product in development called talent
data streams
this is a UI that makes it easy to build
both factions streaming data processing
pipelines and it includes functionality
like interactive data analysis so as
you're constructing the pipeline you can
see samples sort of states of the
intermediate collections as you're
building them and it includes other
things like schema management and
versioning so talent is building these
products on top of Apache Dean because
they believe that building on beam will
allow them and their customers to follow
the evolution of technologies they'll be
able to leverage their data the same way
over time while still having the
flexibility to execute on multiple
runtimes as their needs change alright
so that I'd like to talk a little bit
about getting started with Apache Beam
so since you're at GCD next I think
there's a decent chance that you'd be
interested in running this technology on
Google cloud so what that means is that
cloud dataflow is likely going to be
your choice of runner now we do boot
strapping beam over the last year or so
so you'll find that when you come to
Cloud dataflow you have a few different
options for running we have the original
dataflow SDK for Java and this is what
seeded the Apache bean project so in
some sense this is pre beam and it uses
the older com Google Cloud dataflow
namespaces but still fully supported it
works great on cloud dataflow
you're welcome to use any of the Apache
beam releases on cloud dataflow so for
Java that would be the most recent beam
release which is 0 5 at least until next
week ish when 0 6 comes out and from
Python you'll have to wait for 0 6 it
just merged into the master branch so it
hasn't made a release yet although it's
fair at head if you need it so and
finally we encourage you to take a look
at the next generation of dataflow SDKs
right these are based on Apache beams
and what they do is redistribute the
portion of the Apache being ecosystem
that's most commonly used within DCP all
in a single package all in a way that's
been tested to work well together so
this is it's a great way for getting
started with that broader ecosystem when
you're running on GCP now all of these
beam versions you'll notice those
version numbers all come with some sort
of caveats the beam project has not
finalized their API surface yet they've
done it's been a huge amount
turn to come from the original dataflow
SDK to this we had to rename the
packages right every every file move
from comm kugel cloud dataflow to or gap
at CB n-- so the user the kinds of
changes are not that intense but there
are still pretty far-reaching so we've
been getting all of those front loaded
but we the community has not yet
finalized that they've completed that so
there that's actively under discussion
in the community I hope by maybe early
April we'll be able to declare a stable
release and guarantee that major
versions will not be making backwards
incompatible API changes but other than
that these data for F CKS are fully
ready to run on Google Cloud dataflow so
if you're interested you can go and
check them out and there we go so this
talk is the end of a wonderful
conference there were a number of other
sessions during this conference that
were related to Apache beam if you
didn't catch these in person I really
encourage you to go back and find the
videos ty was talk from yesterday goes
into more details on the the beam model
sort of the evolution how it unifies
matchin streaming the instant insights
talk is really about how to build a data
processing pipeline across all of the
technology in Google cloud platform and
include the use of beam and cloud
dataflow to do that and then finally
there was a talk this morning it was
really about the building of the beam
community so we took something there was
a single company proprietary project and
we built a thriving open-source
ecosystem around it the whole new
project under the umbrella of the Apache
Software Foundation so really that talk
is about the journey of both sort of the
code and the developers involved and how
we kick-started that community so of
course you know you should go to the
beam website we've got a lot of
information there you can use it to get
started with any of those runners that I
showed you today there's also some great
podcast videos other links for learning
more about the beam model and also of
course information on how to get
involved how to come join the developer
mailing list how to start contributing
to the project's Tyler wrote some
articles for a Riley called the world
beyond bash these are also a great way
to learn more about the beam model if
you need some airplane reading for your
way home and then finally if you want to
start using Apache beam on cloud
dataflow today
you can come and check out the data flow
documentation and we'll have pointers
there you'll see the site being in
transition so we still fully support the
original pregame pre beam releases but
we also have the new beam ones coming up
alongside those alright so with that I'd
love to take some questions hi my team
we do a lot of stuff in bigquery
but we're hitting a couple of
limitations here and there and looking
to merge sort of stream and batch
directly against big storage files but
for equivalence operations have you done
any performance benchmarking in versus
bigquery and and being on data flow you
know I don't have the data on that
directly but Sam a greedy who is in the
back corner there might be able to help
you out on this performance questions
thank you so on my team was heavily bet
on Sparky's in Scala because of the
repple we like actually going to the
building process of seeing how the data
is being transformed every stage and
that's something why we have started
spark those didn't have any of those
source capabilities in the pipeline you
can actually just interact with your
Python as you're building it similar to
spark so I think the beam model
interactive is one of those places as we
work on sort of pulling the best
patterns out of the underlying runners
interactive is something that's not
usually done in the beam model right now
but I think there's definitely been a
lot of interest in it so I'd love to see
the community moving in that direction
there is no Scala SDK on top of cloud
dataflow Scala DSL that Spotify is
written called geo SC IO
which is available on github and you can
use on top of I think they still build
on the current cloud dataflow release
1/9 but it's moving towards being built
on top of Apache beam going forward you
can definitely check that out they do
have some sort of reptile based
interface as well that they build on top
of beam okay thank you
oh I would like to understand that if
the bean community currency developed a
variety of the connector or the sink for
storing the result or yeah so the thing
in beam so we have an i/o so there are
plenty of i/o connectors out there
already in the ecosystem right Hadoop
input basically everything can be read
as a Hadoop input so we are building a
compatibility layer into beam right now
I think it might still be in full
request that's coming very soon it'll
allow you to basically unlock any of the
Hadoop inputs so those will just run
however beam actually has its own i/o
API that you can use to teach it about
new data data sources and things and
it's a little more flexible than the
Hadoop input API so the reason we
develop the new API is that we really
want to give runners the right hooks
that they needed to do some more
efficient execution so if you look at
beams i/o api is our source API what it
allows you to do is not just clear how
to divide your implicate up into X
splits and then read a split it also
lets you talk about the progress through
reading one of those splits and how to
further subdivide so with that let's the
service view is basically decide that
because this machine is misbehaving in
flow or because some data is complex if
it sees a straggler shard which is you
know always a huge problem in these
batch rate systems it can go ahead and
subdivide some of that work steal it
from that worker and give it to somebody
else who's done but building that
additional flexibility did require some
additional API hooks so basically where
deems that now is you can unlock
anything at sort of the level it is
elsewhere in the ecosystem and also
we're building out more and more support
for these more efficient stream or more
efficient APs
all right well wonderful please feel
free to come up grow questions if you
like I've got a handful of bean stickers
left that are there on the podium and
please come join us in the bean
community
[Music]